meet between these two after realizing
they will face each other in the world
chess championship match
magnus carlsen in what he's normally an
expert in the end game right
yeah sort of missing out on the winning
chances yeah it feels like his
calculation wasn't quite
what it usually is over the last few
moves
and okay there we go napoli actually
bring his knight to attack white's rook
that rook will move and then black will
just bring his pawn down
one square to try and trade pawns yeah i
think if
magnus carlsen is to win uh the world
championship match against the pontiac
he's going to have to grind out these
end games a bit better
yeah he's going to be have to be super
accurate napoleon actually
once you give him a chance he will take
it and there we go the pawns disappear
from the board and the players just
agree a draw
king versus king no chance magnus not
even trying to win that one
miraculous save by no pomiacci wow i
can't believe it we just saw the first
game between these two after nepo won
the candidates it is
a draw and